I believe in this phrase man I don't see
a problem with it and and they they came
a period I remember there was and I
talked about it in the book but it was
an advert for Lloyd's Bank
you know these adverts right they go
they go which way is the culture wind
blowing oh yeah yeah blokes are [__] man
up so this advert was a string of
celebrities basically saying that they
hated the phrase man up and I thought
that's a real shame because I think
obviously anything can go to excess
right if you're Manning up means that I
don't know you don't go to chemo that's
bad that's too far but I think for the
most part like a phrase like man man up
is sort of like a call to arms for men
isn't it it's basically saying take
yourself less seriously take some
responsibility for the situation fall
back a bit you know like if if you've
got like a load of family staying over
and there's not enough beds right and
you're just deciding who's gonna sleep
on the couch it's really uncomfortable
makeshift bed is it going to be Granddad
no is it going to be the women middle
age no he's gonna be the kids no it's
gonna be the younger male you know and I
think that's quite a good thing to make
yourself less important and I also
thought it's a shame because the amount
of things that bloke could lay claim to
seem to be diminishing whereas the
amount of things that women sort of
celebrate about themselves is fairly
well established you know in terms of I
mean that song by I'm Every Woman you
know yeah I mean they're literally
claiming to be like [__] oracles and
it's all I can read your thoughts right
now and nobody really challenges that so
I thought could we just keep could we
keep Manning up so the book is in a
lighthearted way I guess trying to to
offer up Arguments for why things like
banter and man flu exist and what kind
of function they they have oh and it's
such an important
point because
if you look at what's going on in our
society where
You could argue particularly certain
elements of it demonize men and then
everyone Rings their hands when you get
a figure like Andrew Tate emerge and go
why is this this is terrible what why is
this one you've been trashing men
forever however long you've been saying
they're toxically masculine they're evil
blah blah blah obviously someone who
comes along and is going to subvert that
is going to get a huge audience yeah I
mean I suppose the argument that
progressors might make is they'll often
say well you've had 2 000 years Lads and
I I just think all right I can
understand that as a man of 46 that I've
had certain privileges at times I can
see that I just don't know if you're a
12 year old boy whether that makes as
much sense less so if you're a
seven-year-old boy and every single
animation you seem to watch seems to
involve a strong female lead and a
nervous guy who gets there in the end
right I started to notice that all these
films all these kid films so it's nice
for me to be represented I'm going to be
honest with you I mean I watched a Super
Mario film and I thought Mario is the
absolute hero of that but of course he
can't get over the line without Princess
Peach can Annie just explaining
everything that he's doing wrong and her
being heroic and him just reluctantly
almost falling over the line as as a
hero figure so I guess yes people like
Andrew Tate come into that space and
it's I think most young males would
would see the issues with some of what
he's saying but mainly they're just like
well there's somebody Ada is celebrating
you know masculinity which is
um you know something they might not see
as much certainly in Western popular
culture but also just on a simple level
you know not just him but like the the
sort of manosphere as it's called he's
they're saying things that just seem
true I guess when they start saying
women like guys with money they're like
yeah you know that that's that's
reasonable you know uh women like tall
guys women like athletic guys and yet
you know there's the kind of thing that
if you were on a discussion panel show
on Radio 4 you'd have to caveat is it
right yeah you'd have to go look it
could be said it could be said that in
certain scenarios and I'm by no means
all and you have to do all these weird
[__] small print terms and condition
things and you go yeah but in wider
Britain not of these things aren't
contentious
foreign